es la única de las tres líderes
opositoras que sigue en belarús marjah
kolésnikova líder de las protestas
contra el actual presidente fue detenida
mientras intentaba entrar en ucrania en
la madrugada del martes la líder de la
oposición en el exilio svetlana chicanos
kaia exigió la liberación inmediata de
su colaboradora a las figuras de la
oposición son retenidas bajo cargos
falsos intimidados y amenazados o
expulsados del país por completo ayer
mismo una de las líderes de las
protestas pacíficas mariah kolésnikova
fue secuestrada watch el lunes por la
mañana hombres no identificados vestidos
de negro retuvieron a mariah kolésnikova
y la empujaron a un minibús marcado con
la palabra comunicaciones con rumbo
desconocido según informó su equipo de
campaña los dos aliados que la
acompañaban también miembros del consejo
coordinador para el traspaso pacífico
del poder habrían logrado cruzar la
frontera hacia ucrania por su parte la
agencia de noticias oficial informó que
la dirigente opositora fue detenida en
la frontera cuando intentaba abandonar
ilegalmente belarús no hubo ningún
comentario de la policía de minsk
kolésnikova y otros miembros del equipo
de campaña del opositor víctor baba rico
anunciaron el mes pasado la creación de
un nuevo partido de oposición llamado
juntos crítica acérrima de lukachenko y
miembro del consejo de coordinación de
la oposición kolésnikova ha desempeñado
un papel importante en semanas de
manifestaciones masivas que acusan al
actual mandatario de amañar su
reelección las autoridades bielorrusas
ya han detenido a varios miembros de
este consejo e interrogado a otros
incluyendo a kolésnikova en una
investigación sobre un supuesto intento
de tomar el poder